مشاهدينا تتواصل الان في ميناء بورسودان
عمليه اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب الان هذه
البارجه الاسبانيه ريناسوفيا تستعد
لمغادره من بورسودان هذه الباخره وصلت الى
هذا المكان مساء الامس وهي الان تحمل على
متنها نحو
166 شخص من رعايه الاتحاد الاوروبي تجري
الان في اخر هذه البارجه عمليات الفحص
الطبي للركاب الذين حصلوا على اذن صعود
الى هذه البارجه استعدادا
لوصولهم الى ميناء جده الاسلامي بالمملكه
العربيه السعوديه كما تحدثت هذه الرحله
رقم 31
منذ بدء عمليات الاجلاء من هنا من ميناء
بور سوداند وبالتالي هكذا تجري هذه
العمليه الصعبه والمعقده لعمليه الاجل
بواسطه تنسيق لجان عليا هي تعمل على تسهيل
كل الصعوبات وكل
التحديات التي تواجه عمليه
الاجلاء للرعايه الاجانب سواء كان من
قياده المنطقه العسكريه بولايه البحر
الاحمر وكذلك ايضا بالتنسيق مع سفاره
المملكه العربيه السعوديه طبعا هذه الرحله
سبقتها رحلات من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
القوات الملكيه البحريه وكذلك ايضا من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والمملكه
المتحده وفرنسا والصين جميع هذه الرحلات
تغادر من هنا من هذا الميناء من بورسودان
وصل عدد الذين غادروا السودان نحو 12 الف
شخص غادروا منذ بدء عمليات الاجراء في
الثاني والعشرين من ابريل الماضي متوقع ان
تتزايد عمليه
الاجلاء خلال الايام المقبله طبعا مع
ازدياد وتيره الحرب بين الجيش السوداني
وايضا قوات الدعم السريع محمد عثمان
العربيه من ولايه البحر الاحمر شرقي
السوداني لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات